oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans une nouvelle édition
confiné de going down les médias
traditionnels des pays de l'otan mettent
en garde les gens d'investir dans le
bitcoin la monnaie non contrôlés par les
régulateurs des banques centrales
soutenu par les gouvernements
et ce après que la valeur du bitcoin a
grimpé sans parler de la flambée de
certaines actions déclenchées par des
activistes cherchant à nuire au
portefeuille de hedge funds
institutionnels nous recevons dans notre
émission rogers vers le fondateur de
bigpoint com qui nous rejoint depuis
saint barthélémy dans les caraïbes
merci d'être avec nous rogers je dois
vous dire qu'ici au royaume uni alors
que le bitcoin flambert je parle là des
chiffres du btc des articles cinglant
ont été publiés pour dire aux gens que
ce n'était pas du tout l'avenir les
puissantes élites sont elle terrifiée
par la crypto monnaie oui les acteurs en
place ont toujours peur des nouveaux
joueurs ambitieux qui vont leur enlever
des parts de marché et c'est exactement
ce que nous voyons se passer avec les
modèles numériques dans le monde entier
elle constitue une menace pour l'actuel
état des choses parce qu'il est plus
facile plus rapide moins cher et plus
fiable de recevoir et d'envoyer les
paiements en utilisant les crypto
monnaie plutôt que le système bancaire
existant le modèle opérationnel actuel
des systèmes financiers traditionnels
est donc menacé tout comme internet et
netflix était imbattable par rapport à
blockbuster ou comme la caméra de
l'iphone d'apple
irrésistible comparé aux appareils photo
kodak il en va de même pour les monnaies
numérique les acteurs des marchés
financiers en place ne vont pas aimer ça
mais ça va continuer de plus en plus de
gens vont les utiliser
cela va s'étendre à plus de gens à
travers le monde et avant même que vous
soyez au courant tout le monde utilisera
des monnaies numérique comme tout le
monde utilise son iphone au lieu de
kodak pour prendre des photos
aujourd'hui la presse économique est
beaucoup plus intéressés par ce que font
les hedge fund ce que font les marchés
boursiers ce genre de choses il ne parle
pas vraiment des cartes de crédit de
tous les autres éléments de
l'architecturé financière
or avec l'apparition des crypto monnaie
les banques centrales doivent bien
comprendre quelque chose
quels conseils donneriez-vous à jérôme
powell de la réserve fédérale des états
unis
andrew bailie gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre à christine lagarde de la
banque centrale européenne
ils savent probablement ce qui se passe
ou je ne sais pas peut-être pensez-vous
qu'ils ne comprennent pas ce qui a lieu
mais s'ils ont conscience de cette
renaissance de la monnaie de cette
renaissance du capitalisme que
devrait-il faire fermer les yeux et se
boucher les oreilles il n'y aurait
quelque chose n'est pas une solution
changement qui vient vous devez vous
éduquez en apprendre davantage à ce
sujet et la meilleure façon de le faire
est de commencer à l'utiliser envoyer et
recevoir de la monnaie numérique avec un
de vos amis ou effectuer un paiement en
ligne
il y à plus de 100 milles site web qu'il
accepte c'est vraiment l'avenir
l'invention des monnaies numérique est
l'une des inventions les plus
importantes de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité à égalité en importance avec
l'invention de la roue de l'électricité
et d'internet
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important ignorer les monnaie numérique
aujourd'hui reviendrait à ignorer
internet en 1992 ou quelque chose comme
ça c'est juste le début les choses ne
font que commencer mais c'est vraiment
la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que toute personne où qu'elle
se trouve sur la planète peut désormais
recevoir ou envoyer à toute autre
personne dans le monde de l'argent sans
avoir besoin de l'autorisation de la
banque d'angleterre de la réserve
fédérale des états unis de tout banques
locales ou de quelqu'un d'autre pour
faire ça c'est littéralement un système
de monnaie électronique en pair à pair
qu'on ne peut arrêter dans le monde
entier c'est une chose fantastique pour
toute l'humanité car cela stimule le
commerce et renforce la coopération de
par le monde
toute personne qui essaie de retarder ou
d'entraver l'adoption des monnaies
numérique retardent et entravent le
progrès de l'humanité
à ce sujet même si ce n'est pas bien sûr
en lien direct avec les plus de 40
millions de personnes aux états unis qui
ne peuvent pas manger ce soir
en ce qui concerne les gens qui
envisagent d'investir peut-être
n'ont-ils que quelques dollars
que pensez vous du fait qu'on leur dit
toujours que ce que rogers raconté trop
compliqué quand ils vont sur un site
pour se renseigner c'est toujours trop
compliqué et ce n'est pas tout on nous
met constamment en garde quant au fait
que c'est utilisé par des criminels ou
tout cela relève essentiellement du
trafic de drogue criminelle du meurtre
de masse de l'escroquerie que leur
diriez vous eh bien je pense que vous
pourriez avant c'est exactement le même
argument concernant la cia ou le
dollars américains que ça relève du
meurtre de masse que ces criminelles
comme le trafic de drogue et que c'est
de l'escroquerie
donc si vous voulez vous plaindre de ce
genre de choses je crois que vous
devriez tourner votre regard vers la cia
ou le dollar américain oui certaines
personnes utilisent des choses comme le
bitcoin pour des activités illégales
mais dans l'ensemble c'est un instrument
merveilleux pour tout le monde parce que
quelqu'un peut envoyer à toute autre
personne ou ce soit et recevoir
n'importe quelle somme d'argent
instantanément et presque gratuitement
et il n'y a pas besoin de permission
c'est fantastique vous devez être un
tyran vraiment fou pour penser que c'est
une mauvaise chose pour les gens que
d'avoir le contrôle de leur propre
argent
c'est un bienfait pour toute l'humanité
il est très facile de démarrer sur
bitcoin points comme peu importe dans
quel pays vous vous trouvez et
n'investissez pas ne dépensez pas plus
d'argent que ce que vous pouvez vous
permettre de perdre
mais vous savez vous pouvez continuer la
meilleure plateforme pour commencer
c'est peut-être noise point qu'à h vous
pouvez obtenir environ un dollar de
bitcoin cash et vous amuser un peu c'est
une plateforme de type twitter des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
utilisent tous les jours ils obtiennent
un peu de bitcoin cash sur nos ce point
cash c'est vraiment un site web
intéressant qui a été lancée récemment
qu'on voit certaines plateformes sur les
réseaux sociaux qui résiste à la censure
commencé à fonctionner en ligne a
utilisé des monnaies numérique
il ya également d'autres plateformes
disponibles
il recommande ont évidemment rien dans
cette émission strictement réglementée
vous pouvez perdre tout votre argent et
c'est maintenant de psychologie vous
avez eu à faire à des questions
psychologiques dès le début de votre
carrière dans le projet bitcoin points
comme je voudrais vous demander quelle
serait la motivation de ceux qui
suggèrent qu'une crypto monnaies telles
que le bitcoin est la crypte monnaie en
général est une fausse route qu'il ne
faut surtout pas entrer là dedans les
gens devrait-il parler à leurs honnête
courtier à leur directeur de banque
je suis pas sûr qu'ils existent encore
et éviter cette révolution dont vous
parlez eh bien à mon avis c'est juste
que les acteurs du marché en place ont
peur de la concurrence
je suis sûr que blockbuster vidéo dirai
à tous leurs clients de ne jamais
utiliser netflix de ne jamais diffusé un
film en ligne
et idiot venez à notre magasin en
personne mais non il est beaucoup plus
pratique pour les gens d'utiliser des
plateformes comme netflix ou youtube
pour consommer leurs propres médias
il sera beaucoup plus utile pour les
gens d'utiliser des modèles numériques à
l'avenir que de recourir aux services de
la banque d'angleterre de barclays ou de
bank of america ou quoi que ce soit les
monnaies numériques sont plus rapides
moins cher plus fiable et plus facile à
utiliser que les voies traditionnelles
les gens vont finir par les utiliser
c'est ce que nous voyons se passer dans
le monde
je pensais que vous aviez donné une
réponse différente parce que n'est ce
pas plus important que cela ce n'est pas
comme les vidéos du vendredi soir
cela menace certains aspects basé sur
l'idéologie sur la politique sur notre
concept même de liberté certaines
personnes vont jusqu'à dire ça c'est
pourquoi j'ai posé une question sur les
banques centrales
si de plus en plus de gens font cela où
seront les banques centrales et donc ils
les gouvernements qui disent qu'ils ne
contrôlent pas les banques centrales
mais qui ont clairement des relations
avec elle oui n'importe qui peut devenir
sa propre banque centrale aujourd'hui il
devient de plus en plus difficile de
convaincre les gens d'utiliser votre
propre monnaie émise par votre banque
centrale les acteurs traditionnels que
sont les banques centrales comme la
réserve fédérale ou la banque
d'angleterre leurs jours sont comptés
les gens n'en n'auront plus besoin les
gens peuvent recourir à d'autres outils
comme les monnaies numérique qui ne sont
pas émises par une autorité centrale et
il y a des règles du jeu équitables qui
s'applique à tous si vous êtes une
banque centrale traditionnelle vous avez
votre machine à imprimer de l'argent
magique vous pouvez imprimer autant
d'argent que vous le souhaitez à tout
moment pour n'importe quelle raison
et vous vous attendez à ce que les gens
l'utilisent et soudain ce nouvel outil
arrive ce qui fait que les gens n'ont
plus besoin de votre machine à imprimer
de l'argent magique vous allez vous
sentir menacé vous allez probablement
faire tout ce que vous pouvez pour
essayer de retarder d'empêcher ou
d'entraver ce phénomène je vais mettre
ma casquette de complotiste la taille
des blocs est maintenant limité à 1 méga
quelque chose d'autre a été introduit
qui s'appelle bitcoin cash qui
fonctionne à très bas coût un nouvel
utilisateur ne peut pas posséder moins
de 10 dollars de bitcoin car les frais
pour les recevoir son supérieur à 10
dollars donc si les frais sont de 10 $
vous ne pouvez pas recevoir 10 de là
donc je suis très enthousiaste à propos
de bitcoin cash et vous l'avez beaucoup
soutenu jeu
dire des opérateurs disent qu'il existe
des méthodes de réduction des
commissions mais qu'en est il si vous
n'êtes pas un militant qui croient
philosophiquement un peu comme les gens
de voyage dit et de gamestop en l'aspect
politique de l'investissement à long
terme dans le bitcoin ou dans les crypto
monnaie que faites vous si les journaux
ou les gens qui vous entourent vous
disent qu'il va y avoir une sorte de
régulation et que vous voyez
immédiatement vos investissements
baisser comment réagissez vous à ces
flashs infos presque quotidiens
affirmant que joe biden va annoncer un
nouveau cadre réglementaire
je pense que cela montre très clairement
que ces institutions centralisée
traditionnels ont beaucoup trop de
pouvoir et de capacité de contrôle et il
influence trop ce qui se passe dans le
monde
je n'ai jamais rencontré joe biden joe
biden ne me connaît pas non plus
pourquoi devrait-il avoir un mot à dire
sur ma vie ou sur mon argent sur mes
affaires plus que moi qui aurais mon mot
à dire sur sa vie ou sur ces affaires à
lui je pense que chaque individu sait
comment gérer sa vie je vais donc voir
plus de gens être maîtres de leur propre
vie de leur propre destin et les
monnaies numériques sont un outil
fantastique pour combiner avec internet
permettre aux gens de faire précisément
ça donc à l'avenir je pense que nous
verrons de moins en moins de contrôle et
de régulation de la part de
gouvernements centralisée et en même
temps de plus en plus d'importance du
marché lui même regardé le magazine
consumers report
ils font bien un meilleur travail de
protection des consommateurs que
n'importe lequel de ses organes de
contrôle gouvernementaux je veux voir
plus de sources comme rt et consumer
report protéger les gens contre les
escroqueries les investissements
frauduleux et tout ça les gouvernements
ou un très mauvais bilan en matière d'
aide à la population
si vous regardez la sécurité sociale aux
etats unis c'est essentiellement la
définition même d'un système de ponzi et
tout le monde est obligé d'y participer
donnons aux gens la possibilité de se
retirer avec leur propre argent et de
choisir comment ils veulent épargner
pour leur propre retraite et avec ses
choix vient la responsabilité mais les
gens doivent avoir cette responsabilité
et ce choix mais c'est très compliqué il
existe aujourd'hui de nombreux toqué de
bitcoin différents je sais que vous
travaillez sur bitcoin cash mais ils
sont si nombreux et différents
croyez vous que les gens au pouvoir vont
juste laissé tomber
diront 'vous savez le genre de
réglementation qui imposerait de savoir
si un site web est bien sécurisée ou
quelque chose comme ça vous pensez
vraiment qu'ils les accepterons cela
comme réglementation plutôt que de dire
nous allons commencer à bloquer bitcoin
en utilisant des afflux massifs de
capitaux pour acheter des blocs chain et
puis les contrôles et transformer le
monde entier en une sorte de corée du
nord où les gens normaux n'ont même pas
accès à internet
il est impossible d'arrêter ses monnaie
numérique donc la question n'est pas de
savoir si ces personnes au pouvoir vont
permettre que cela se produise
la vraie question est de savoir ce qu'il
pourrait faire pour empêcher cela tout
ce qu'ils pourraient faire c'est
peut-être retarder ou entravaient les
choses ralentir ce processus mais il est
fondamentalement impossible de l'arrêter
à ce stade pour faire ça il devrait
atteindre tout le réseau internet dans
le monde entier et le garder et un et je
ne vois pas cela comme un scénario
probable
il n'y a pas si longtemps on a été
témoin ils l'ont fait pendant l'épidémie
de coronavirus je parle là de la
politique de quantitative easing qui
l'ont mis en place sur le marché
auriez vous pu prévoir qu'il rendrait
encore plus riches les personnes les
plus riches de la planète avec ce
quantitative easing qui implique
l'impression d'argent
pensez vous que ce serait politiquement
acceptable le pessimiste en moi était
absolument sûr qu'il fallait faire ça
l'optimiste en moins espérer qu'il ne le
ferait pas mais encore et toujours les
gouvernements du monde entier me
déçoivent et le pessimiste en moi a eu
raison il semble généralement servir à
récompenser leurs amis et punir leurs
ennemis c'est ce que font les
gouvernements partout dans le monde
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il est temps
pour eux d'avoir moins de contrôles sur
les jambes
le temps est venu pour chaque individu
d'avoir plus de contrôle sur sa propre
vie surtout maintenant que chaque être
humain sur la planète avec un smartphone
bon marché a accès à toute la
connaissance humaine
si vous ne savez pas quelque chose vous
pouvez le rechercher sur internet et
tout lire sur le sujet vous serez un
consommateur informé sur ce sujet
particulier selon moi cela signifie tout
simplement que nous en tant que société
avant de moins en moins bon
loin de ces institutions centralisée
pour diriger le monde il est ridicule de
croire qu'il existe une solution unique
pour des dizaines de millions ou des
centaines de millions de personnes dans
tel ou tel pays
il y a des gens et des individus qui ont
des besoins des désirs différents les
scellés ne les forçait pas à s'intégrer
dans le système universel des
gouvernements traditionnelle pour la
banque centrale européenne que vous
soyez dans le sud de l'italie où dans le
centre de l'allemagne n'a pas
d'importance en ce qui concerne l'euro
vous surpris que des pays qui sont
perçus comme des ennemis du
néolibéralisme de l'otan n'adopte pas la
crypto monnaie plus rapidement que
l'iran le venezuela la russie la chine
pourquoi la russie la chine ne sont
elles pas pressés d'adopter la crypto
monnaie
on le ressent tiraient peut-être
immédiatement si elle le faisait on
verrait des fluctuations encore plus
importante qu après l'investissement de
1 5 milliard de dollars dès lors je
crois que le bitcoin et les monnaies
numérique s'appelait mécanisme sans trop
de contrôles de l'occident mais cela
mine également des pays comme la corée
du nord si elle avait commencé à
utiliser la crypto monnaie si les gens
avaient accès à internet
le régime s'effondra immédiatement c'est
la même chose pour des pays comme le
venezuela ou d'autres endroits qui ne
sont pas alignés sur le temps et sur
l'occident cela sape leur pouvoir aussi
il n'y a aucun gouvernement au monde qui
seraient désireux de saper son propre
pouvoir
et c'est ce que font les monnaie
numérique elles permettent aux individus
d'avoir plus de contrôle sur leur propre
vie au détriment de la capacité de
l'état à contrôler leur propre vie après
la pause on continue notre entretien
avec le fondateur de bitcoin point corps
[Musique]
alors que nous sommes de retour pour
poursuivre notre conversation avec le
fondateur de bigpoint com rogers rogers
n'estimez vous pas que vous ressembler
parfois à l'un de ses revendeurs d'or à
la télévision quelle est la différence
entre l'achat d'or et l'achat de crypto
monnaie et bien comme nous l'avons vu
aux états unis le gouvernement américain
a réussi à rendre illégale la possession
d'or et ils sont allés enlever leur or à
des personnes à travers le monde
désolé à travers les états unis et ça a
été un énorme problème qui a duré des
décennies avec la manade numérique si
vous l'utilisez dans un portefeuille
réel où vous contrôlez l'argent vous
même personne dans le monde ne peut vous
prendre ces fonds vous pouvez le
transférer partout dans le monde pour
effectuer des paiements instantanément
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça avec de l'or
mais avant la crypte au manège était
l'un de ses partisans de l'or qui
croyaient que l'or et l'argent était
meilleur que le dollar américain ou
l'euro ce soit d'autre mais plus tard
lorsque les modèles numériques sont
arrivés ça a été un bon en avant
même par rapport aux métaux précieux je
me suis donc impliqué dans des choses
comme bitcoin cash
oui l'or reste à son niveau pré
pandémique
comment choisissez-vous la crypte
monnaie et ne dites pas d'utiliser
bitcoin cache tout le temps quels
critères faut-il appliquer si vous
considérez les différentes crypto
monnaie outre le fait de les voir comme
un moyen idéologique de saper le pouvoir
existant parce qu'il ya tant de
différents types de monnaie de token
certains disent que c'est là la base
philosophique théorique de la liberté
qu'on trouve derrière l'idée originale
du bitcoin au lieu de la version
perverti qu'on peut dire observé avec
intérêt
il vous faut comprendre quelle monnaie
numérique sont les plus utiles et seront
utilisés par le plus grand nombre de
personnes et c'est ce que nous voyons se
produire avec éthérée hommes les gens
font des choses incroyablement
intéressante avec était réelle des
milliards et des milliards de dollars
par jour en dollars et en actifs
numériques toutes sortes de choses sont
échangées sur intérêts hommes les gens
utilisent maintenant des blocs chains
pour faire circuler des dollars
numérique à travers le monde
alors quels sont les modèles numériques
les plus utiles ce sont celles qui
seront utilisés par le plus grand nombre
de personnes en tant qu'investisseur
vous devriez choisir les monnaies les
plus populaires et c'est là qu'il faut
verser votre argent le grand wayne
gretzky a dit à propos du hockey que
vous devez patiner à l'endroit où le
palais va être et non là où ils étaient
en train d'aller c'est la même chose
avec l'investissement dans les monnaies
numérique vous ne versez pas votre
argent là où tout l'argent se trouve
déjà
vous investissez là où l'argent va aller
c'est pour cette raison que je suis un
grand fan de bitcoin cash et intérieure
et voilà encore une fois ce sont les
plus commerciaux en ce qui concerne
votre métaphore du hockey oui c'est très
bien jusqu'à ce que ceux qui font le
marché et les gens connaissent leur nom
puisqu'ils ont tous été renflouées par
le contribuable en 2008 viennent et le
font eux-mêmes parce qu'ils ont pour
reprendre votre métaphore des crosses de
hockey beaucoup plus longue
comment peut-on utiliser la crypte
monnaie use même en appliquant des
méthodes que vous avez choisi comme un
acte de désobéissance civile contre les
idées dominantes l'économie ayant
bénéficié aux plus riches dans la
société
chaque fois que vous utilisez le dollar
ou l'euro ou toutes autres monnaies
traditionnelles vous utilisez la monnaie
que les gouvernements utilisent pour
renflouer toutes les entreprises
politiques connectés et ensuite arnaquer
les citoyens chaque fois que vous
utilisez une monnaie numérique vous
renoncez ce système traditionnel en
faveur d'un système où il y a des règles
du jeu qui sont les mêmes pour tout le
monde
que vous soyez goldman sachs ou john
smith sur main street great au même
niveau que tout le monde donc chaque
fois que vous devez acheter ou vendre ou
payer ou recevoir un paiement pour quoi
que ce soit n'importe où essayez
d'utiliser une monnaie numérique temps
je voudrais revenir à quelque chose que
vous avez mentionné plus tôt pourquoi
pensez-vous que les journalistes ne
peuvent pas comprendre que les dollars
sont utilisées pour des transactions
dans le trafic de drogue tandis que les
crypto monnaie ne sont que des monnaies
vous ne pouvez pas blâmer la monnaie
pour ce qui fait avec elle peu importe
le fait que la cia a été l'un des plus
grands trafiquants de drogue de
l'histoire et il utilisait les dollars
au moins la cia l'admet et vous vous
l'admettrez aussi j'admettrai que les
gens peuvent le faire avec des modèles
numériques oui alors que les gros titres
et c'est d'effrayer les gens et encore
plus les futurs investisseurs l'histoire
de gamestop les gens la connaissent
peut-être d'une publication sur reddit
qui cherchent à prendre sa revanche sur
ses grandes entreprises du marché en les
empêchant de gagner de l'argent
je veux dire comment la commission des
services financiers de la chambre des
représentants va t'elle parler à robin
wood
melvin capital et citadelle les
régulateurs américains ont déjà cités à
comparaître quelqu'un appelé keith guil
également connu comme au ring kitty
attendez vous à ce que ceux qui prônent
une révolution du capitalisme comme vous
semblez la décrire finissent par être
cité à comparaître et attaquer sans
remords par les pouvoirs en place tout
ce qui se passe montre exactement à quel
point c'est injuste les grands joueurs
reçoivent toujours un traitement spécial
et les petits acteurs sont toujours
abuser c'est ainsi que le système
financier traditionnel effet est
intentionnel alors que tous ses actifs
sont cryptés sur la blouse chain il n'y
aura aucune sorte de robin des bois qui
pourrait tout simplement suspendre les
échanges pour tout le monde ou
désactiver l'achat de gamestop tout le
monde sera sur un pied d'égalité donc
plus vite nous pourrons avoir ses
valeurs et le reste crypté sur la blood
chaîne plus vite vous allez vous
débarrasser de ces autorités centrales
comme la sc la commission de contrôle
des marchés il ne protège pas un
consommateur
il protège les acteurs du marché en
place et tous les consommateurs
réguliers sont obligés de payer pour que
la sc protège le grand joueur c'est
juste une vaste comédie qui vise à
protéger l'ancien système financier
plutôt le monde comment sera utilisé
actifs numérisés sur la blood chaigne
plus vite nous aurons des règles du jeu
équitables pour tout le monde pas
seulement aux états unis pas seulement
au royaume-uni
pas seulement au sein de l'ue mais pour
chaque être humain sur la planète
il ne s'agit certainement pas de
l'égalité des chances et des conditions
équitables comme nous l'avons vu avec
l'intervention soudaine d'elon musk cela
a provoqué une flambée des prix est
riche contrôleront toujours le pouvoir
c'est juste que le pouvoir de ceux qui
sont politiquement connectés sera réduit
et bien je suis bien plus grand fan des
le musk que n'importe quel politicien
dans le monde
les tesla sont des voitures incroyables
paypal est une entreprise magnifique et
il a créé toutes sortes de choses que je
trouve très pratique dans ma vie
quotidienne
d'accord il n'a pas été élu
démocratiquement mais tout étudiant en
sciences politiques vous demanderez
pourquoi les gens qui soutiennent ces
nouvelles crypte monnaie crois que cette
puissance politique et militaro
industriel va soudainement cédé son
pouvoir juste comme ça
quoi d'autre faut-il faire au delà
d'encourager plus de gens à utiliser le
bitcoin cela pourrait prendre 20 50 100
ans
rien n'est plus puissant qu'une idée qui
tombe au bon moment et l'argent
électronique en pair à pair est une idée
qui tombe à point nommé pour l'humanité
et rien ne va l'arrêter parce que c'est
un concept puissant et pratique pour les
gens dans le monde entier
une grande partie du monde vit avec
moins d'un dollar par jour
nous ne faisons pas cela très souvent
dans notre émission et je crois que ça
va faire exploser ces gens là car ils
sont généralement exclues de ce qu'on
appelle les médias traditionnels
si vous avez disons 5 dollars comment
pouvez vous essayer de renverser les
structures de pouvoir en vigueur avec
vos 5 dollars vous pouvez changer vos 5
$ pour une monnaie numérique et de cette
façon vous n'allez plus utiliser ces
dollars qui soutiennent les structures
de pouvoir traditionnel alors vous
vivez vous pouvez utiliser un moteur de
recherche pour trouver une bonne
plateforme mais certains pourraient dire
que de toute façon tout servira à payer
une commission alain des parasites au
sommet du bitcoin est de la pyramide de
la crypto monnaie je n'aime pas que cela
ressemble à une publicité mais oui ce
n'est plus pour tout le monde
les frais sur le réseau bitcoin sont
trop élevés et si vous n'êtes pas en
mesure de conserver le bitcoin dans
votre propre portefeuille
cet argent ne vous appartient pas vous
êtes à la merci du dépositaire que vous
utilisez ce qui n'est aucunement
différent de l'utilisation de votre
banque traditionnelle où vous êtes alors
merci
et c'est pourquoi vous avez besoin
d'autres crypte où monet dont les frais
sont faibles vous pouvez deviner
laquelle est ma préférée mais toute
autre monnaie avec peu de frais peut
rendre autonomes l'individu partout sur
la planète
si la crypto mener à des frais élevés et
que tout le monde est obligé d'utiliser
des plateforme centralisée pour détenir
de la crypto monnaie vous perdez presque
tous les avantages permettant d'apporter
la liberté économique au monde entier et
c'est pour cela que je suis partisan des
monnaies numérique qui fonctionne en
fait comme l'argent électronique en pair
à pair avec peu de frais sont
dépositaires
oui vous avez déjà évoqué plusieurs fois
que c'était bitcoin cash est-ce que cela
vous amuse ou cela vous alarme peut-être
une discutable propagande ne se bornent
plus à dire que c'est criminel
ils disent maintenant que la crypto
monette une pyramide de ponzi
je ne sais pas si cela vous semble
amusant ou pas parce que c'est comme ça
que certains activistes considère la
monnaie fiduciaire ces dernières années
qu'en est il du fait que tout ce que
vous soutenez est fondamentalement un
système de ponzi et que de grands
joueurs contrôlent maintenant le marché
et que donc dès qu'il parte
vous perdez tout votre argent le fait
que quelqu'un a dit quelque chose
n'applique pas qu'elle soit
nécessairement vrai
le mot même de ponzi charles ponzi a
utilisé les dollars américains pour son
système et je suis sûr que plus de
système ponzi ont été réalisés avec le
dollar américain qu'avec tout autre
monnaie numérique mais des gens ne blâme
pas le dollar pour cela spécifiquement
c'est la même chose pour la monnaie
numérique
certaines personnes vont tromper les
gens en utilisant des monnaies numérique
ou mettre en place des systèmes de ponzi
ou faire de mauvaises choses
et ce n'est pas un problème propre à la
monnaie numérique le
problème réside dans la façon dont
quelqu'un utilise cette monnaie
numérique les monnaies électroniques
sont bien plus équitable dans tous les
domaines parce que vous savez exactement
quel sera le taux d'inflation alors que
comme nous l'avons vu l'année dernière
avec le dollar américain
nous n'avons aucune idée de combien
d'argent ils vont imprimer cette semaine
ou le mois suivant et continue de nous
surprendre
nous savons que cela ne se produira pas
avec les modèles numériques que nous
utilisons donc il n'ya bien sûr aucune
garantie qu'une monnaie électronique
plus cher augmente au fil du temps mais
il est absolument certain que la valeur
de vos dollar va baisser au fil du temps
mais que se passe-t-il si ceux qui font
le marché achète tout simplement
d'énormes volumes de crypto monnaies
différentes et deviennent ensuite ceux
qui font le marché dans le nombre limité
de blog shane qui régissent les crypto
monnaie ne reviendrions nous pas tout
simplement à la situation précédente
avec des hommes politiques soumis au
lobbying de ceux qui font le marché
ils seront aussi un peu comme la réserve
fédérale et bien si vous pensez vraiment
que cela va se produire mon conseil
serait d'acheter certaines de ces
monnaies numérique avant que les
spéculateurs n'arrivait en achètent des
quantités énormes et ce qui est très
bien c'est que s'ils échouent et ont un
problème il n'y aura personne pour les
renflouer
plus personne ne voudra de dollars car
ils utiliseront ces monnaie numérique
adossés à des actifs réels
il n'y a pas de banque centrale qui peut
en imprimer davantage pour renflouer
ceux qui font le marché
s'ils commettent une erreur ou et font
faillite il y aura des règles du jeu
équitables si les grands acteurs font
une erreur ils doivent en être
responsables de la même manière que si
un petit joueur fait une erreur et perd
son argent il n'est pas renfloué par
washington dc enfin les grands acteurs
ne pourront pas non plus être renfloué
par washington où la banque centrale
et c'est une bonne chose pour tout le
monde qui arrive se trouve enfin dans
des conditions d'égalité
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit en
terrain de jeu égal mais c'est un peu
plus équitable oui certaines personnes
des buts plus près du sommet que
d'autres mais au moins le terrain de jeu
est égal et il ne le modifie pas en
plein milieu de la partie comme ils le
font actuellement
et comme on l'a vu récemment avec le
fiasco de gamestop attendez vous à une
nouvelle réglementation du marché des
actions que ce soit pour un moment le
grand sujet de conversation dans les
médias traditionnels la presse
économique et la radio je m'attends à un
développement plus accrue de la nuit
lisa sion et du cryptage des titres sur
les blogs chains où ils sont beaucoup
plus imperméable aux réglementations
gouvernementales traditionnel c'est une
bonne chose à mon avis et nous verrons
de plus en plus d'associations privé
dirait attention à s'auto ken prenez
garde il vit un problème de sécurité
et j'aimerais voir des choses comme
consumer report remplacer là et se sait
car ils font un bien meilleur travail de
protection des consommateurs
[Musique]